foreign
digital era businesses are actively
seeking a strong online footing driving
a high demand for digital marketing
services this presents an excellent
opportunity for aspiring entrepreneurs
to establish their own digital marketing
agencies if your passion lies in
facilitating businesses to succeed in
the digital realm this step-by-step
guide will Aid you in launching your
very own digital marketing agency in
this video we are going to share with
you few easy steps to start your own
digital marketing agency however to
become a digital marketing expert get
certified into digital marketing with
simply learns post-graduate program in
digital marketing obtain certification
as a retail marketing professional
through Purdue University program
acquire the knowledge to develop and
advertise your personal website using
engaging live Interactive Learning
sessions gain Proficiency in
fundamentals and advanced digital
marketing techniques by engaging with
Harvard Business publishing cases over
20 practical projects collaborative
interaction with chat GPT and AI tools
and access to more than 35 digital
marketing resources for admitting to
this course two years of experience is
preferred so hurry up and enroll Now
find the course Link in the description
box but before we move ahead with
amazing steps to start a data marketing
agency consider subscribing to Simply
Lan and hit the Bell icon to never miss
any updates from us
so let's start with step number one
Define your Niche and services
pinpoint the specific domain of digital
marketing where you possess expertise or
Excel this could Encompass social media
marketing search engine optimization
content marketing pay-per-click
advertising email marketing or web
design
focusing on Specialized Niche will
enable you to differentiate and attract
clients seeking tailored Services Step 2
conduct market research and analyze
competitors
under the comprehensive market research
to comprehend your target audience and
their pain points and the demand for
your chosen Services analyze competitors
to identified Market gaps and
opportunities that can set your agency
apart step 3 develop a business plan
construct a thorough business plan
outlining your agency's objectives
target market unique selling proposition
or USP pricing model marketing
strategies and financial projections a
well-structured business plan will serve
as a navigational tool for your agency's
growth step 4
address legal requirements
formalize your business by registering
it selecting an appropriate business
name and fulfilling necessary legal
obligations
advice from legal experts to ensure
compliance with local regulation and to
draft client engagement contracts step 5
establish an online presence
create a professional website that
showcases your agency Services portfolio
client endorsements and team members
your website should be a mirror of your
expertise and establish your credibility
as a digital marketing agency step 6
build networks and cultivate
relationships participate in Industry
events seminars and workshops to connect
with potential clients and workshops to
connect with potential clients and peers
in the field networking AIDS in forming
valuable Partnerships and gaining
insights to the latest digital marketing
Trends step 7 generate compelling
content
initiate a Blog on your website to
display your proficiency and offer
valuable insight to your target audience
regularly publish high quality content
on subjects related to digital marketing
Trends advice and case studies to
Showcase your agency's expertise and
Authority step number eight cultivate a
social media presence
social media platforms to promote your
agencies and engage with your audience
share your blog post industry updates
success stories and tips to establish
yourself as a knowledgeable figure in
the digital marketing domain step number
nine secure clients
device effective Outreach strategies to
secure your initial clients this might
involve sending introductory emails
attending local business Gatherings
leveraging your existing contacts or
delivering free workshops to exhibit
your expertise
step number 10 deliver exemplary results
success of your agency relies on the
outcomes you deliver to your clients
take strategies for each client based on
their goals and maintain regular
communication regarding progress and
accomplishments embarking on a digital
marketing agency Venture necessitates a
blend of Industry know-how strategic
planning and dedication by delivering
exceptional outcomes by adhering to
these steps and remaining adaptable to
the ever-evolving digital landscape you
can pave the way for a thriving agency
that empowers businesses to flourish in
the digital world if you like this video
do subscribe to our channel to never
miss any updates on latest digital
marketing techniques listen to what our
Learners say about our courses in their
own words
restarting your career in a new country
that too in a new sector after a career
break is anything but hi my name is riti
and I am a digital marketer by
profession I already had experience in
sales and public relations so I wanted
to learn digital marketing so I opted a
professional certification program in
digital marketing from Purdue University
offered by simply learn on the basis of
my past experience and on my newly
developed skill I landed my first
freelance project with a company called
the best part about this job is it is
remote I can stay at home I can be with
my kids and I can also focus on my
hobbies too so here we wrap up this
topic thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here